هذه ليست سوى
وسيلة نقل أساسية ، فهذه هي مرسيدس
مايباخ 6 كابريوليه 20
قدمًا بقوة 750 حصانًا ، وكلها تتسع لشخصين فقط ،
إنها الفخامة المطلقة البالغة 6 أمتار لكل سيارة
سادي مايباخ هي
العلامة التجارية الفرعية الفاخرة لسادي ، فهي تخلق أفخم
إصدارات مرسيدس الأكبر  ومعظم
السيارات باهظة الثمن ، هذا جزء من سلسلة
من السيارات النموذجية التي من المفترض أن
تمثل أنواعًا من الأشياء التي
قد تصنعها مرسيدس مايباخ في يوم من الأيام ، يشبه الأمر تقريبًا
أن تكون في مؤسسة يو إس إس ،
سفينة الفضاء التي أتحدث عنها بشكل صحيح ،
تم تصميم التصميم الداخلي لإظهاره.  انطلاقا من
حقيقة أن هذه هي كبلات سيارة كهربائية
داخل أنبوب مركزي تضيء في الليل ،
لذا بالنسبة للنجوم الثلاثة على المقاعد
في الوقت الحالي ، فهي مجرد سيارة عرض لا أستطيع أن
أتخيل أن أي شيء مثل هذا
سيترك أبدًا خط إنتاج مرسيدس
هناك حدود من الناحية العملية ،
هل يمكننا رؤية سيارة مثل هذه
تعتقد أنها موجودة في السوق بالطبع
يمكننا دائمًا تخيل أننا بصراحة
لدينا الكثير من المكاتب إذا ر  مرحبًا ،
أتمنى ألا أضطر أبدًا إلى إيقافها